[Musique]
il ya cabine qu'elle a on va regarder
tous les deux qu'il ya dans la cabine et
on va voir si on bluff ou pas tu nous
diras ce que tu vois je dirai ce que je
vois les téléspectateurs vont voter est
ce qu'on bluff ou pas et vous aussi vous
dire et qui dit la vérité avec mangane
on va d'abord regarder ce qu'il ya
derrière petit gros cette émission nous
réserve pas mal de surprises alors
attends donc je vais vous dire je vais
vous dire le produit doit faire quoi
mais je regarde ce qu'il a et où je
bluff ou pas je dis ce que je vois vas-y
je dis ce que je vois derrière la cabine
pour l'instant il n'y a rien sur la tête
de ma mère ils ont pas encore mis le dos
[Rires]
et moi et moi je regarde souvent au
stress genre comme ça les amis en
attendant que la cabine soit plein j'en
redemande à l'équipe de cyril hanouna de
m'apporter moi aussi une perruque parce
que je veux être bref sauvetage
je sais pas si c'est les perruques mais
il ya un truc dont on sait aujourd'hui
qui est beaucoup plus calme quand il
saura sera d'être en perruque t'inquiète
pas il s'agit des frères away je sais ce
que je fais ce que je suis ce que je dis
ce que je vois pas je sais ce que je
vois ouais ouais quoi je vais te dire
moi je vois je vois et toi tu sois tu
bluff ou pas en fonction de ce que je
veux dire moi je vois un âne déguisé en
côte françois un âne blond et là je dois
déjà je dois dire que si c'est vrai ou
pas non toi tu dois regarder tu dis ce
que tu vaux pas ça se voit que j'ai pas
compris le jeu ou pas
vous aurez tout griffé avant d
il est atteint merci alors dis ce que tu
vois je suis fais tu vas rentrer dans la
cabine aaa
s'il vous plaît monsieur
mais moi je dors tu n'as pas gagné même
chose que moi je vois ouais un mec
ouais on dirait donald trump ouais mais
c'est pas donald trump donc le sosie de
dole entre moi je pense pas je pense pas
que ce soit jugé jane je ne pense pas
que ça lui et sa femme
à votre avis qui qui bluffe qui à votre
avis mathieu qu'est ce qu'il ya c'est
vous qui avez raison c'est l'âne
selanne a dit ann lanneville là
attention
est ce qu'il ya un acte déguisé en coûte
françois lyonnais
je voudrais faire une spéciale dédicace
à david guetta
à ce jeu télé c'est le seul endroit au
monde au lieu de te regarder dans le
miroir tu fais juste aller chercher ses
ballons alors tu as les et kde garde on
va voir le premier est bien le premier
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais juste qu'on voit
c'est au père noël à la tristesse de la
perruque que l'on met à la merci merci
d'être venu merci à tous et à bercy très
beaux cuirs merci attention
[Applaudissements]
dad attention j'y vais j'y vais je
regarde ce qu'il ya dans cette deuxième
kabila ne peut guérir à rumeurs
j'ai vu le dos j'ai vu le dos c'est bon
alors écoutez moi bien là ici ici il ya
un cas mais les bleus ça veut dire à
caméléon mais juste avec une perruque
blond rigoler il ya un cas mais les
bleus voilà mon gars tu dis ce que tu
vois
[Rires]
moi j'ai vu un
il ya un comique way qui s'est mis dans
le corps de david guetta
ouais et qui a poussé très fort ouais et
du coup ce qui se passe c'est qu'il ya
le comique on voit un peu sa tête et
tout autour il ya une ambiance de la
ville guetta et c'est très perturbant de
boîte de nuit donc à un comique il ya un
très bon cru pour david guetta est un
comique de boîte de nuit avant kravitz
qui a raison gad gad d'add up yade 1 me
voyais pas du tout à mon histoire de cas
bel et bien attention
[Applaudissements]
et sa boulette à vancouver du modèle
bon ça te valeur
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attendez la verrerie gaulle à la sécu
réunissez vous dis là dit bonjour 4
david guetta bonsoir non mais je suis à
fond
non mais j'adore on aurait dû faire les
annonces mais moi dès qu'une perruque
c'est pour ma gueule il savait de toute
façon était magnifique mais schumann moi
qui a pas de sens dans cette émission
aujourd'hui non il n'ya pas la face on
essaie mais tout à gauche sortant des
paroles en porte-voix je n'entends pas
j'ai trouvé une seule où je suis venu en
[Applaudissements]
question je te jure on dirait une répète
dans un garage ça va régler le son rêve
il ya pas de religieux est vaste et le
plus important c'est que même du mal à
te voir
[Rires]
malgré tes dires moi j'étais inconnu à
l'odeur tout de suite c'est parce que je
vous jure on s'entend elie semoun merki
[Applaudissements]
les castaldi ah oui d'accord j'ai vu
j'ai vu j'ai vu l'eau je vous le dis il
y as derrière patty jabbi coni en blond
qui fait un saut avec un stage et il
nous ce que tu vois ça c'est très
plausible
ouais je serai aussi très bien sûr
moi j'ai vu ophélie winter voilà tout
simplement peter gade gâteries l'échec
donc vous avez ophélie winter voit tout
de suite qu'il y avait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'ailleurs c'est mon gars tu parles avec
nous
c'est un shérif à l'encore ou pas à oui
ah oui ah oui ah oui oui alors là sans
regret je veux pas dire mais regarde toi
d'abord on regarde regarde tu sais c est
non ok juste que tu veux mais je dis ce
que je veux je dis la vérité certains
as-tu des vérités toi on va il ya dave
et laurent romejko sur un solex
ce jeu est super long pour moi j'ai pour
moi à katrina patchett de danse avec les
stars
aa avec igor et grichka qui ont des
membres c'est-à-dire dès menton blondy
et non violents
vous pensez que ces gâteaux des dm oui
bah oui mais pas c'est que ces gars qui
a raison des séries les membres longue
série
[Applaudissements]
et j'avais bien sur terre
jours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci